[Music]
here we are on the Internet you missed a
good [ __ ] already uh-oh
Tom wait ask you Steve sure what did you
think of Woody Harrelson's portrayal of
you in Game Change I thought it was
terrific no I mean it was like it was a
very very strange experience but I got
to know what he's a really nice guy he's
a great guy he's a great guy you don't
know I'm like I do and uh he's a great
guy he's such a talented actor I love
his movies and and if he can't ever
adieu the next game change you would
step in for him yeah absolutely
okay Jim what would you say to people
who claim Politico has a conservative
bias a conservative bias I don't we get
defeated on both sides people when
you're in the media regardless what
paper at people say you're from the left
view from the right
our whole thing has always been to be
down in the middle I think there's a
plenty of noise on the left and the
right what there isn't a lot of and it
gets to the Baltimore paper gets to
what's happening in New Orleans there's
not a lot of just reporting just fact
out reporting we don't have 200 some
employees of those 130 are involved in
the editorial process it's all because
of the name obviously very focused on
governance in politics and they're you
know if you are full of it like people
are going to know follow-up questions so
in it how do you feel about the fact
that New Orleans will now be the largest
US city without a daily newspaper that's
your city well is that they went to
three days a week right The Times the
nearly or new orleans picayune didn't
they go to right I mean they're online
but they're going to a printed paper
three days a week that's crazy because
there are seven days in a week well I'm
not I'm not particularly wedded to the
idea of newsprint I feel like cutting
down trees and throwing them on people's
doorsteps is an anachronism and has
meant for someone you know that the
delivery system is going to be digital
what I what I am wedded to the idea of a
newsroom is the idea of a paid
professional journalism which I don't
believe the amateur hour can replace
what high end journalism is and should
be you're not calling him the amateur oh
right no I know you being online is know
that being online being an in print
that's not the issue the issue is if
we're going to digital can you create
enough of a revenue stream
to pay the reporters to cover the beats
to have a bead structure so that there's
some schnook covering the zoning board
for long enough so that when they slip
something in the agenda they're going to
put a strip a strip joint next year not
that it's a bad thing but when they're
gonna put a strip joint next to the
elementary school you know it in advance
before it starts getting built you know
everyone thinks that wreck the plans
Christine and I have for after that show
written list a question for you if you
believe in limited government Christine
why should the government intervene on
social issues like gay marriage and
women's reproductive health
so you've answered that one before I've
always said on those issues that they're
States state issues and on the issues
that change it I mean it's still about
the government whether it's a state or
federal level and because it comes to
determining when you have your rights
infringed upon the person who decides
that should be someone who is a part of
the community and who's gonna be held
accountable to those decisions
we're worried so no I mean I
accountability I have a whole chapter I
know I don't care who the person ridgey
my right side that it does whatever the
reality is there is a freedom food chain
and this is what sets me apart is a
conservative from a libertarian because
I do believe that the government should
have some laws I consider myself a
limited government conservative like I
don't understand the people in our party
who think it is okay for the government
to mandate a medical procedure to a
woman I mean
[Applause]
you have law after law in this country
and state legislators these efforts you
know I'm pro-life but you know if it's a
legal procedure in the country how does
the state mandate an invasive medical
procedure well this day combination
relation the state doesn't mandate it
right I mean the Democrats are trying to
say that by their moves this past week
to unlimite striction x' on this very
risky person I could like actually come
in on your side here for a minute like
see I always separate abortion with the
other social rights issues that the
Conservatives talk about like gay rights
like to be against gay rights to me it's
just stupid because it just comes from
the Bible I support it but yet I always
say you do not have to be religious to
be against abortion I mean I'm
pro-choice but I get it that there are
people who believe because it's
undeniably a life that's it's not a life
that's born yet but it's undeniably
becoming one I get that that is an issue
you do not have to you mean atheist and
be pro-life I've covered the Baltimore
City Council and I've even had a little
bit of a hand in covering the Maryland
State Legislature and if you think like
the the intellectual power of those
bodies is in some way superior or more
nuanced in cinah to the harvest the
United States Congress yeah that's just
nothing but it couldn't be low there's
nothing but I don't have the stomach to
inter interfere in this person I don't
underst well you can't have a one-size I
don't know all about Roche but I don't
understand this basic philosophy that we
can do things on a state level like this
is the whole argument with Mitt Romney
and Romney care oh it worked in
Massachusetts where people have gall
bladders but federally it wouldn't work
because in Kentucky they don't I mean
people get sick the same in every day
people have abortions or not in every
state to say why is it work on a state
level I'm not because well first of all
we have the Tenth Amendment and the
Tenth Amendment protects state
sovereignty so the tomatoes our founders
understood that accountability it's got
just really freedom and the Tenth
Amendment is everything not enumerated
specifically to the fed along to those
data the state's right and these
certain things are not enumerated what
about the Defense of Marriage Act then
which would seem to be an abrogation of
the Tenth Amendment because marriage has
always been defined out-of-state father
right I agree and that's why we have it
because when it comes to that issue the
states can define a civil union a
domestic partnership and then the states
can determine how that is enacted and
what we see happening all across the
country is that issue of same-sex
marriage pits the First Amendment with
the Tenth Amendment yes and for example
in cases like New Jersey there are
churches that have lost their tax-exempt
status because they don't have civil
union couples and things like then you
can applaud because you think that's a
good thing but the church has the First
Amendment right to define its own
religion or shine marriage according to
its religion and the Tenth Amendment
says the states will determine how these
things are defined and if you don't like
what's going on in New Jersey then you
become an apartment so what you have
done during the greeted and weep Tenth
Amendment what would you have done
during the civil rights movement except
what would you have done during the
period when the civil rights movement
was emerging you talked about
accountability at states rights level
you needed a federal government that was
gonna allow people to fight medley yeah
they're not the only movement Union this
was this was one the civil rights war
was won on the state level civil rights
was watched it was not by individuals
getting up now have you seen you must
know needed a federal government to take
on Bull Connor civil rights
I was founded to Nu I thought there was
the 82nd airborne ended slavery
I thought the 82nd levy you've seen that
Norman Rockwell page where the true
where the guys escorting a little black
child a federal that's a federal troop I
mean Kennedy that's what cost the 16th
amendment the foot the federal
government powers of the federal
government is to protect its defense
both foreign and domestic right but in
that sort of situation it's a domestic
threat you're talking about a whole
movement that truly started when the
Republican Party was founded to end
slavery and it was the downstroke the
Republicans did enslave you got to give
that to Lincoln and the Republicans have
been strongly behind the Black Knight
ever since all right we gotta go thank
you very much everybody
real time to do more ask bill and its
guests your questions right after the
show at HBO calm